HE'S WON TWO STRAIGH GAMES.
RESURGENCE ON THE BLUE LINE FOR
HIM.
>> Garry: THE MONTREAL
CANADIENS HAVE REALLYFITZGERALD.
BJORK IS THERE TRYING TO GET BY,
THEN SUZUKI.
THAT SPUDS OUT A PUCK T SPACE.
HE TAKES OFF WITH IT.
DUMPS IT IN.
AFTER ITR TRYING TO CATCH UP TO
IT.
UP
FOR SIX THE OTHER NIGHT AGAINST
THE COLUMBUS BLUE JACKETS.
LOLO
BIRO AFTER IT.
GETS THE C C DAHLIN HITS THE BRS
AND DODGED THE CHECK OF
HE BAILS OUT AND THEN COMINGGHEO
CUT IN LIKE THAT AND HE LOWERED
THE BOOM ON HIM.
HE'S GOING TO THE LOCKER ROOM.
JAKE EVANS ON IT.
FEEDS IT ACROSS.
BROKEN UP AS ANDERSO AWAY INAYIG
EARLIER THAT THEY'VE HAD
>> John: 21DAHLIN.
ALL THE WAY BACK AROUND BEHIND
THE NET.
WANTED TO GO TO THE POINT, BUT
IT'S CUT OFFFF
TURNOVER HALFWAY THROUGH
THE FOUR ON FOUR.COZENS WAS GOIN
OPPORTUNITY TO STEAL ON CRAIG
ANDERSON.
HE'S IN!
SECOND OF THE NIGHT
ROMANOV GETSALTY,
HOOKING.
>> John: THERE IT IS. A REALLY E
TONIGHT.
HAT HAPPENS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT -- WE WERE
CHATTI
YOU'RE NOT DIGGING IT OFF THE
WALL ON YOUR BACKHAND.
>> John: SCORES!
UNDER ST. LOUIS, SIX GOALS,
SAM.
LOST AN EDGE.
HE PLAYING.
HE HAS OPTIONS. GOING AFTER.
TRACKS IT DOWN.
GOES TO THE NET.. AWAY BY ANDERK
SUZUKI.
SAMUELSSON STUCK WITH IT. BOX FR
TRIPPING.
HERE'SL TIP IT OUT.
HERE'S EVANS WITH IT.